Notebook LM plus Gemini 3.1 flashlight
is insane. Today I'm going to show you
something wild. Google just dropped a
combo that nobody is talking about. It's
free. It's fast. And it can build you a
real AI app in under 10 minutes. I'm not
even joking. By the end of this video,
you're going to look at AI completely
different. Stick around because this
one's a game changer. So, here's the
deal. Everyone's obsessed with the big
flashy AI models right now. But what if
I told you the real power move is speed,
not size, speed? That's exactly what
Google figured out with Gemini 3.1
flashlight. Let me break this down so
simple a 5-year-old could get it. Gemini
3.1 flashlight is Google's new
lightweight AI model. It's built for one
thing, being crazy fast. We're talking
near instant responses. That means if
you're building a chatbot, a support
tool, a landing page helper, anything
that needs to think quick, this is your
engine. Now, here's where it gets
interesting. You pair that speed with
Notebook LM, which is Google's AI
research tool, and you've got something
special. Notebook LM takes your
documents, your notes, your research,
and turns it into structured, usable
stuff. Summaries, outlines, scripts,
frameworks is like having a research
assistant that never sleeps. Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO
agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. So, Flashlight is the
engine, Notebook LM is the brain. Put
them together and you've basically got
an AI app factory. And I'm about to show
you exactly how to use it step by step.
Step one, open up Notebook LM. This is
your research phase. You're going to
paste in a prompt that tells Notebook LM
to go deep on whatever topic you need.
Let me give you a real example. Say
you're running an AI automation
community like the AI profit boardroom.
You want to create content that shows
people how AI can grow their business.
You'd pay something like this into
Notebook LM. You are my AI research
assistant. Topic: How AI automation
helps small businesses get more leads,
save time, and scale faster. Summarize
the latest strategies, tools, workflows,
and real use cases for AI automation in
business growth. Focus on practical
examples that a community like the AI
profit boardroom would use to help
members get results. Hit enter. And just
like that, Notebook LM gives you a full
structured research summary. Clear
features, real use cases, organized
insights, no fluff, no guessing, just
solid info you can actually use. Now,
step two, this is where it gets fun. You
take that research and you refine it.
You paste another prompt into Notebook
LM that says something like this. Using
the research above, rewrite this in a
high energy format. Focus on what makes
AI automation a must-have for business
owners. Why the AI profit boardroom is a
place to learn this. How members can use
these tools to get more customers and
save hours every week. Keep it short,
make it punchy, make it feel real. And
boom. Notebook LM turns your raw
research into content that's ready to
use. You've got hooks, you've got
talking points, you've got stuff that
sounds like a real person wrote it
because you guided it with the right
prompts. And one more thing, if you're
creating all this content with Notebook
LM, but nobody is finding it online,
you've got a traffic problem. That's
where SEO comes in. If you want more
leads, more traffic, my team can help
you rank higher on Google. Check the
link in the comments and description to
order AICO online and let us handle your
back links while you focus on growing
your business. And if you want to rank
number one and get more customers, join
the SEO Elite Circle. That's where we
actually teach you how this works. No
theory, no recycle tips, just the exact
AI SEO systems we're using right now. We
break everything down step by step with
real workflows, weekly live support, and
clear actions you can follow without
guessing. If you're serious about
scaling with SEO and AI, this is where
you start. Hit the link in the
description and join the SEO Elite
Circle today. Now, step three, this is
the big one. You turn notebook LM into
your app architect. You paste in a
prompt like this. Based on everything
above, design a simple AI app that can
be built using Gemini 3.1 Flashlight
inside Google AI Studio. The app should
help a community like the AI profit
boardroom on board new members faster.
It should answer common questions about
AI automation. It should recommend the
right resources based on what someone
needs. And it should respond instantly.
generate a clear app concept, core
features, target users, and a
readyto-paste Google AI Studio prompt
that's optimized for flashlight speed.
And here's what Notebook LM gives you
back. A full app concept, a features
list, a target audience breakdown, and a
production ready prompt you can
literally copy and paste straight into
Google AI Studio. Notebook LM just
became your product strategist, your
prompt engineer, and your UX thinker
allin one. Now, step four, this is the
moment you go to Google AI Studio. You
select Gemini 3.1 flashlight as your
model. You paste that prompt in. You
click run, and you wait. Except you
don't wait because it responds in less
than a second. That's the whole point.
That's the insane part. You just built a
working AI app from research to launch
using two free tools and a handful of
prompts. And it runs fast enough to use
in the real world. Let me put this in
perspective. A few years ago, building
something like this would have taken a
dev team weeks, maybe months. Now you
can do it in a single sitting. That's
the shift that's happening right now.
And the best part is you don't need to
be technical. You don't need to write
code. You just need to know how to ask
the right questions. That's what AI
automation is all about. It's not about
replacing people. It's about giving
regular people superpowers. Think about
what you could build with this. A
customer support bot for your website
that answers in real time. A content
assistant that helps your team write
better and faster. an onboarding tool
for a community like the AI Profit
Boardroom that walks new members through
everything they need to know without you
lifting a finger. The possibilities are
wild. And here's what I want you to
understand. This isn't just another AI
update you scroll past. This is a real
shift. The models are getting faster and
the tools are getting easier. That means
the people who move first win the most.
Small creators are going to beat big
teams. Solo founders are going to
outpace funded startups because speed
and smart automation matter more than
headcount now. And that's not hype.
That's just what's happening. Notebook
LM gives you the intelligence. Gemini
3.1 Flashlight gives you the execution.
Together, you can build things that feel
instant, things that actually work,
things that solve real problems for real
people. So, here's what I want you to do
right now. Open Notebook LM. Try this
workflow. build something even if it's
small because once you see how fast this
works, you're not going back. Julian
Goldie reads every comment. So, make
sure you comment below and tell us what
app you'd build with this setup. Like
this video if you want more real AI
workflows and subscribe so you don't
miss the next breakdown. And one more
thing, if you're creating all this
content with Notebook LM, but nobody is
finding it online, you've got a traffic
problem. You can have the best AI tools
in the world. You can build the smartest
apps. You can create amazing content,
but if nobody sees it, none of it
matters. That's where SEO comes in. And
that's exactly what my team does every
single day. We help businesses show up
on Google where their customers are
already searching. We build the
backlinks. We handle the strategy. We do
the heavy lifting so you don't have to
figure it out yourself. For clients who
want more leads, more traffic. So, if
you're tired of creating great stuff
that nobody finds, check the link in the
comments and description to order AISO
online. Let us handle your back links
and your rankings while you focus on
growing your business. And if you want
to rank number one and get more
customers, join the SEO Elite Circle.
That's where we actually teach you how
this works. No theory, no recycle tips,
just the exact AI SEO systems we're
using right now. We break everything
down step by step with real workflows,
weekly live support, and clear actions
you can follow without guessing. If
you're serious about scaling with SEO
and AI, this is where you start. Hit the
link in the description and join the SEO
elite circle today.